>>THE BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE SAID NICOLAS CRUZ HAD AN
AR-15 IN HIS POSSESSION.
IT'S BEEN USED IN MASS SHOOTINGS
IN AURORA, COLORADO,
CONNECTICUT, TEXAS, AND LAS
VEGAS.
>> THIS HAPPENS NOWHERE ELSE
OTHER THAN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, THIS EPIDEMIC OF MASS
SLAUGHTER, THIS SCOURGE OF
SCHOOL SHOOTING AFTER SCHOOL
SHOOTING.
IT ONLY HAPPENS HERE, NOT
BECAUSE OF COINCIDENCE, NOT
BECAUSE OF BAD LUCK, BUT AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF OUR INACTION.
>> IT DIDN'T TAKE HIM LONG TO
GO RIGHT TO GUN CONTROL.
CHRIS MURPHY FROM CONNECTICUT.
THIS A PROBLEM WITH THE GUN OR
THE SHOOTER?
LET'S LOOK AT THE AR-15, WHAT
MAKES IT SO SAFE AND WHAT IT
TAKES TO GET ONE.
AARON, YOU KNOW THIS WEAPON
WELL.
I'VE FIRED IT MANY TIMES.
MY FAMILY OWNED A LOT OF GUNS.
I SHOT GUNS SINCE I WAS, I DON'T
KNOW, 6 YEARS OLD.
IT'S LIKE ALL WEAPONS.
IT'S VERY DANGEROUS IN THE HANDS
OF THE WRONG PERSON AND IF
YOU'RE NOT TRAINED AND YOU HAVE
HAVE A CRIMINAL DISPOSITION, A
VIOLENT DISPOSITION, IT CAN BE
TURNED INTO A KILLING MACHINE.
CHRIS MURPHY WANTS TO MAKE THIS
ALL ABOUT THE WEAPONS.
>> HE ISN'T REALLY QUALIFIED TO
ASSESS THREAT AND MANAGE RISK.
THIS IS A SECURITY ISSUE.
IT'S NOT A WEAPON ISSUE.
THAT KID HAD PARENTS.
WHERE'S THE PARENTS?
WHO RAISED THIS KID?
WHAT WAS GOING ON IN THE HOUSE?
THAT'S THE FIRST PLACE I WOULD
BE LOOKING.
PARDON ME FOR MY VOICE.
THERE IS A MENTAL HEALTH
EPIDEMIC HERE THAT'S BEING
CONFUSED WITH A GUN PROBLEM.
YOUR LAST GUEST TALKED ABOUT HOW
ISRAEL MANAGED TO COMPLETELY
SQUASH ALL OF THE SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS IN THE '70S AS A
RESULT OF TERRORISM.
THE WEAPON, JUST TO GO BACK TO
YOUR FIRST POINT, THE AR DOESN'T
STAND FOR AUTOMATIC RIFLE.
IT'S THE COMPANY THAT
MANUFACTURED IT FOR THE
MILITARY.
NOW THERE'S DOZENS IF NOT
HUNDREDS OF COMPANIES THAT
MANUFACTURE THEM AND SELL THEM.
IT'S SEMIAUTOMATIC.
IT'S NO DIFFERENT THAN A
HANDGUN.
IN FACT, THE ROUND IS EVEN
SMALLER.
IT'S A 22-CALIBER ROUND IF YOU
WERE TO BREAK YOU THE DOWN.
THE OTHER DIFFERENCE IS IT
LEGALLY PURCHASED TO FIRE
WITHOUT A FEDERAL FIREARMS
LICENSE ON FULLY AUTOMATIC.
THE M4, WHICH THE AR IS MODELED
AFTER, IS A FULLY AUTOMATIC
RIFLE FOR FULLY AUTOMATIC FIRE.
I THINK THERE IS SOME
GRANDIOSITY AFTER BEING AT WAR
FOR THE LAST 15 YEARS, WHICH
MAKES KIDS AND PEOPLE WANT TO
ASSOCIATE WITH THIS WEAPON.
BUT THE FACT IS IT LOOKS LIKE A
MENACING M4.
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
>> IT'S A SEMIAUTO WEAPON, BUT
THE MAGAZINES, THE CLIPS CAN
HOLD MORE BULLETS.
SO THAT'S WHAT THE -- CHRIS
MURPHY WILL SAY.
IT'S NOT JUST THE WAY THE WEAPON
LOOKS.
IT'S THE FACT THAT THE CLIP
HOLDS MANY BULLETS.
HE HAD A LOT OF CLIPS IN HIS
POSSESSION APPARENTLY.
BUT IT'S A POPULAR WEAPON.
>> IT'S ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE IT'S A REALLY GOOD
SELF-DEFENSE WEAPON.
I WOULD HAVE ONE IN MY HOME FOR
HOME DEFENSE.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE HAVE THEM IN
THEIR HOME BECAUSE IT SHOOTS
VERY STRAIGHT.
YOU CAN CARRY MORE AMMUNITION IN
IT.
AND IT'S ACTUALLY SAFER BECAUSE
YOU'RE GOING TO A LOWER -- YOU
HAVE TO PARDON ME.
YOU HAVE A LESS LIKELIHOOD OF
SPORADIC FIRE OR HITTING
INNOCENT PEOPLE IF YOU'RE USING
IT FOR HOME DEFENSE BECAUSE IT
SHOOTS REALLY STRAIGHT.
IT'S ACTUALLY A VERY SAFE
WEAPON.
IT'S EASIER TO SHOOT THAN A
PISTOL.
IT'S GOT MORE POINTS OF CONTACT
FOR STABILITY.
IN THE HANDS OF THE WRONG PERSON
-- AND AGAIN, WHERE WAS THE
PARENTS?
WHAT WAS THE HOME LIFE OF THIS
CHILD?
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE INVOLVED
HERE THAN THE WEAPON.
>> THERE ARE SOME THINGS WE
LEARNED.
HIS MOTHER DIED LAST YEAR.
HE WAS ADOPTED.
HIS PARENTS, LINDA AND ROGER
CRUZ.
HE'S FOLLOWED THE IRAQI FIGHTERS
ONLY AND THE SYRIAN RESISTANCE.
WE DON'T KNOW MORE, BUT THERE'S
SOMETHING GOING ON THERE.
WE'LL LEARN MORE ABOUT THAT.
ONE MORE QUESTION FOR YOU, GIVEN
YOUR EXPERIENCE WITH ISRAEL AND
THE SCHOOLS, WHAT COULD THESE
SCHOOLS IN THE UNITED STATES DO
TODAY BEYOND HAVING ONE SECURITY
GUARD AND A BUZZER AND SOME
BULLETPROOF GLASS IN THE FRONT,
WHAT ELSE COULD THEY DO?
>> THANK YOU FOR ASKING ME THIS
IMPORTANT QUESTION.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ISRAELI
SECURITY AND AMERICAN PRIVATE
SECURITY IS THAT WE INVEST IN A
SECURITY GUARD.
WE PHYSICALLY TRAIN THEM TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT BEHAVIOR TO
PREDICT VIOLENCE, WHICH MEANS
THE AVERAGE SECURITY GUARD IS
TRAINED IN BEING ABLE TO RESPOND
TO AN ACTIVE SHOOTER, WHICH
MEANS THEY'RE ARMED IN THE
SCHOOLS.
TWO, OPEN THE JACKET AND CHECK
THE BAG.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING IN WITH AN
AR, A PISTOL, A BOMB.
IT WORKS FOR ANY KID WHO'S
POORLY RAISED AND IT WORKS FOR
TERRORISTS.
SO WE CHECK THE BAGS, OPEN THE
JACKETS, BUT WE TRAIN THE
SECURITY.
WE INVEST IN THE INDIVIDUAL
SECURITY GUARD SO HE CAN PREDICT
BEHAVIOR.
THERE'S 21 DIFFERENT RED FLAGS
SOMEONE'S GOING TO DO WHEN
THEY'RE ABOUT TO COMMIT AN ACT
OF MURDER.
YOU CAN TRAIN THEM IN THAT.
JUST SPEND THE MONEY ON THE